A number of years ago my parents were
zoche to purchase an apartment in Eretz Yisrael
and that opened up a whole new series
of shailos about how to relate to time
that they spend in Eretz Yisrael. It makes
my life a lot better when I go
to Eretz Yisrael that I have a home
to stay at that's sort of, not exactly
my own, but sort of my own, but
it raises a whole bunch of shailos. So
the first shaila, the first issue that was
omed al haperek for them was that now
that they own a place in Eretz Yisrael,
they still own their home that I grew
up in and live there most of the
year, but now that they have an apartment
in Eretz Yisrael, what do they do about
two days of Yom Tov? So this has
become an increasingly complicated issue about how Bnei
Chutz La'aretz should deal with two days of
Yom Tov and I'm not discussing that now.
We've had a halacha shiur on that and
how Bnei Chutz La'aretz should deal with two
days of Yom Tov. What we're discussing today
is are they Bnei Chutz La'aretz or not?
Meaning, when you own an apartment in Eretz
Yisrael does that change anything? Does that make
you a Ben Eretz Yisrael? So in order
to, so what I'm going to share with
you today is an approach that Rav Asher
Weiss printed in the latest volume of Yeshurun,
a teshuvah he wrote that was printed in
the latest volume of Yeshurun. I imagine it
will be forthcoming in one of his Minchas
Asher but for now it's in the Yeshurun
journal and I thought that his approach resonated
very much with me to the point that
my parents never asked me the shaila but
someone else who's in a similar situation had
asked me the shaila and my netiya right
away was to say a very similar svara
to what Rav Asher Weiss suggests. I just
didn't have the guts to say it, but
now that I know that Rav Asher Weiss
says it, I have the guts to say
you could rely on Rav Asher Weiss. So
here's, here's his approach. He starts off by
telling us there's a teshuvah in the Avkas
Rochel. The Avkas Rochel of course was written
by the Beis Yosef. In Siman Chaf-vav he
writes that Bnei Chutz La'aretz who are oleh
leregel observe two days of Yom Tov in
Eretz Yisrael and they davin b'farhesya and he
says v'davar zeh na'aseh me'az u'mikedem lifnei gedolei
olam v'ein potzeh peh u'metzaftzef. And that's always
been the minhag, it's been done for a
long, long time. No one ever argues about
it, no one ever has a taina. If
a ben Chutz La'aretz spends Yom Tov in
Eretz Yisrael and keeps two days, he's fully
within his rights and he's doing the right
thing and he can davin a Yom Tov
davening on the second day. Chida writes this
way in Birkei Yosef Siman Taf-tzadi-vav, the Pa'as
Ha-shulchan in Hilchos Eretz Yisrael Perek Beis Sif
Tes-vav. That is the, that is the accepted
practice. However, there are three different approaches that
all suggest that a ben Chutz La'aretz and
again, that's not really our topic, but we
have to have some familiarity with it in
order to get to our topic, there are
three different approaches to suggest that a ben
Chutz La'aretz in Eretz Yisrael does not keep
two days of Yom Tov. And even though
we don't accept these three different approaches, it's
important to be familiar with them. One of
them is the Chacham Tzvi. The Chacham Tzvi
in Chelek Aleph Siman Kuf-samech-zayin writes that since
a ben Eretz Yisrael is not allowed to
be mosif an extra day of Yom Tov
it would be a violation of the issur
of bal tosef, so the whole notion that
you keep the chumrei hamakom when you travel
from one place to another, that you observe
the chumros of the place that you came
from and the chumros of the place that
you come to, that's when observing your chumra
is only a chumra. But if you're going
to say that oh, I've come from Chutz
La'aretz and now I'm in Eretz Yisrael so
I'm going to still observe the chumra of
Chutz La'aretz of keeping two days, well in
Eretz Yisrael that's not a chumra, that's a
kula because it's a violation of bal tosef
for Bnei Eretz Yisrael to do that. And
therefore says the Chacham Tzvi Bnei Chutz La'aretz
who visit Eretz Yisrael do not keep two
days of Yom Tov because we cannot apply
the rule of keeping the chumros of the
place from where you came. A similar but
different svara is offered by the son of
the Chacham Tzvi Rav Yaakov Emden in Sheilos
Yaavetz Chelek Aleph Siman Kuf-samech-ches where he says
that this halacha does not really depend on
the minhag of the place, the minhag of
the people of the place, rather it depends
on the etzem hamakom itself. In Chutz La'aretz
there's two days of Yom Tov, in Eretz
Yisrael there's one day of Yom Tov and
that is it. Meaning someone who's a ben
Eretz Yisrael that goes to visit Chutz La'aretz
according to Rav Yaakov Emden keeps two days
me'ikar hadin, not just because mar'is ayin this
that, me'ikar hadin because this minhag has nothing
to do with you, it has to do
with your location and if you are located
in Chutz La'aretz it's two days, located in
Eretz Yisrael it's one day. The Avnei Nezer
Orach Chaim Siman Taf-kuf-lamed-tes says something very similar
as well. Now it happens to be that
there are Rishonim that say explicitly that someone
who is from Chutz La'aretz and visits Eretz
Yisrael keeps two days. Rabbeinu Chananel and the
Ravan in Pesachim Daf Nun-beis Amud Aleph where
the Gemara says amar lei Rav Safra l'Rav
Abba kigone anan d'yadinan b'keviya d'yarcha b'yishuva lo
avidna mahlokes. machlokes b'midbar mai, that he says
I who happen to be familiar with the
calendar, so in the yishuv, in where people
live I don't do it because I don't
want to get involved in machlokes. But what
about bamidbar? So what exactly is he saying?
What's he asking? Says the Rach and the
Ravan, Rabbeinu Chananel and the Ravan, that Rav
Safra wanted to go to Eretz Yisrael and
was pashut that in Eretz Yisrael proper in
the yishuv he's not allowed to do melacha
on Yom Tov Sheni and his only safek
was in the midbar. So that's what he
says: b'yishuv lo avdinan, that I'm not going
to do melacha. That's how the Rishonim understand
that a ben chutz la'aretz in Eretz Yisrael
may not do melacha. However, in the Sefer
Even Shlomo on the Ravan, he suggests that
b'yishuv lo avdinan means that lo avdinan, not
that I won't do melacha, I won't make
a Yom Tov Sheni because I'm afraid of
Bal Tosif like the Chacham Tzvi. But the
pashut pshat in the Ravan is like we
said, that you keep two days of Yom
Tov. The Shulchan Aruch HaRav in Siman Tav-Tzadi-Vav
Seif Yud-Aleph writes that bnei chutz la'aretz shebau
l'Eretz Yisrael af al pi she'da'ato lachazor, bnei
chutz la'aretz visiting Israel even if they plan
on going home, ein osin ela yom echad
k'vnei Eretz Yisrael. And that's why I think
Chabad does like that, that they observe only
one day of Yom Tov even bnei chutz
la'aretz who visit Eretz Yisrael because the Shulchan
Aruch HaRav paskens straight like the Chacham Tzvi.
In Kuntres Acharon he quotes the Ravan, so
even though he saw the Rishonim that disagree,
Rishonim that disagree with the Chacham Tzvi, he
still paskens like the Chacham Tzvi. It wasn't
because he didn't see the Rishonim, he himself
quotes the Ravan. In the Sefer Ir HaKodesh
VeHaMikdash, Rav Yechiel Michel Tucazinsky writes that the
Rav of Yerushalayim Rav Shmuel Salant held also
that me'ikar hadin ha'halacha is like the Chacham
Tzvi. Then there is a third sevara to
be meikel. Rav Dov Ber Karliner in Kuntres
HaMinhagim on page twenty-two in She'elas David has
a different sevara to perhaps be meikel. Maybe
the whole din of Yom Tov Sheni shel
Galuyos is only because of a chashash shema
yachzor davar l'kilkulo, that things might go back
to the way they were and we're going
to have to be mekadesh al pi hare'iyah
and therefore you're going to keep doing things
the way you do them now, meaning why
is it? We're already experts in the calendar,
we know when the real day of Yom
Tov is. So why do we still keep
shnei yamim tovim shel galuyos? Because what happens
if we go back to being mekadesh al
pi hare'iyah? Then we're not going to know
when Yom Tov is and then we're going
to end up observing, we're going to end
up observing one day when really we should
be observing two days. But he says that
whole sevara doesn't apply in Eretz Yisrael because
even if yachzor davar l'kilkulo in Eretz Yisrael
we'll still be familiar, we're still going to
know which day is really Yom Tov. So
as it turns out, there are three different
ways in the Achronim to understand why one
might say that a ben chutz la'aretz should
keep one day even in Eretz Yisrael. Rav
Yaakov Emden because it doesn't depend on the
person at all, it depends on the makom.
The Chacham Tzvi because of the Bal Tosif
issue, so it's not a chumra of the
makom that you came from. And Rav Dov
Ber Karliner that in Eretz Yisrael it was
never observed two days of Yom Tov, so
you don't have to worry about shema yachzor
davar l'kilkulo. L'halacha almost all the poskim are
machmir about that issue. I mean l'halacha we
don't pasken like any of these three sevaros,
mamash a ben chutz la'aretz in Eretz Yisrael
generally speaking for the most part we would
assume would keep two days of Yom Tov
and not one day of Yom Tov. But
that is not our shailah. Our shailah is
does owning an apartment make a difference? So
this is a very fascinating question. How do
you decide whether you're a ben Eretz Yisrael
or a ben chutz la'aretz? I have two
homes. I have a home in Eretz Yisrael
and a home in chutz la'aretz. So what
am I? I mean do I determine it
based on which home is larger? That doesn't
seem fair, that seems somewhat arbitrary. How exactly
do I determine what I am? Very difficult
to find mareh mekomos on this topic. But
leave it to Rav Asher Weiss in the
Teshuvos Maharit Tzalon Siman Nun-Bet he says as
follows: ve'od ani mesupak im nasa isha achas
b'eretz yisrael ve'isha achas b'chutz la'aretz. He doesn't
talk about a person who has two homes,
just he talks about a person who has
two wives. We don't recommend this. But a
person has two wives, one in Eretz Yisrael,
one in chutz la'aretz, ve'kove'a dirato l'yamim yemimah
shana im isha zu ve'shana im isha acheres.
He spends one year with that isha, one
year with the other isha, variety is the
spice of life and ve'kayotzei b'zeh. I'm just
joking, don't try this at home. ve'kayotzei b'zeh
davar kavua and he does that each and
every year switches back and forth. heichi dayaninan
leh l'inyan ha'umdos, how do you deal with
this? So he says: v'ka'es ein biyadi sifrei
haposkim lachapes din zeh l'heyosi al haderech lishkon
kavod artzenu ka'asher betchilah b'siyata d'shmaya, omnam she'kefi
hanireh, he says I would think im hadavar
b'kevius shana kan ve'shana kan. If it's a
set thing o ein ha-davar kavua ein le-cha
ela me-komo ve-sha-ato. How do you determine where
you live? Where are you right now? u-motza-ei
ha-shabbat asher yavo lo mi-she-shovet be-chutz la-aretz dino
ke-ven chutz la-aretz u-motza-ei ha-shabbat asher yavo lo
mi-she-shovet be-eretz yisrael dino ke-ven eretz yisrael ke-van
she-ha-davar kavua bilti shinui kach nireh li. He
says you have mamash two homes, where you
are determines what you are. So if you
are in eretz yisrael in your home in
eretz yisrael you are a ben eretz yisrael.
If you are in chutz la-aretz you are
a ben chutz la-aretz. And Rav Asher points
out that tshuvot minchat yitzchak chelek daled in
the end of siman daled quotes from a
ha-griz Mintzberg, from the gedolei yerushalayim who asked
the imrei emet who wanted to be oleh
to eretz yisrael and to live some of
the year in eretz yisrael, some of the
year in chutz la-aretz, what should he do
about the mo'adot? And this ha-griz pasken that
someone who lives six months in eretz yisrael
has din of eretz yisrael when he's in
eretz yisrael but no less than six months.
It's got to be at least six months.
And then this is based on a shach
in yoreh de'ah siman resh-yud-zayin se'if katan lamed-zayin
where the shach quotes from the ha-mabit. The
rama over there says someone who's noder hana'ah
from someone who lives in a particular city.
I take a neder I'm not allowed to
get hana'ah from a guy who lives in
that city. Well how long does he have
to live in that city for? How much
time does he have to spend in that
city to qualify him as someone who lives
in that city? So says the ha-mabit quoted
by the shach, six months. So says the
minchat yitzchak quoting this ha-griz Mintzberg that that
the same would apply here. You've got to
be at least six months in one place
to be considered a ben of that place.
Rav Asher Weiss thinks that that is somewhat
arbitrary. He says no, dinei nedarim are a
totally separate area of halacha. By dinei nedarim
what's the the one major rule in dinei
nedarim? Everything is holchin achar leshon bnei adam.
It all depends on what people refer to
it as. It's not based on a reality,
it's based on what someone probably meant when
he said I won't get hana'ah from people
who live in that city. But when it
comes to halacha defining what is a ben
eretz yisrael versus a ben chutz la-aretz Rav
Asher thinks it's strange to suggest that it
should be based on six months. He says
rov is is most likely not the kove'a
over here. He says when is rov a
kove'a? rov is kove'a when you're trying to
be dan on kol. You're trying to say
rubo ke-kulo. So that's where you would you
would you would say rov. But when when
once the ha-mabit has taught us that you
could be you can live in two places
and be both a ben eretz yisrael and
a ben chutz la-aretz and you don't have
to say rubo ke-kulo, you don't have to
say that rov is everything, so then mi-meila
it we wouldn't follow we wouldn't follow rov.
So used to be that people would say
okay where do you work? Where's your job?
But in a global economy where people can
work remotely from you know from just about
anywhere, anywhere with an internet connection people can
can do their work and people often have
businesses all over the place. Hard to say
that it should depend on where your job
is, that that should be the kove'a of
of what what you are, of where where
you are. The minchat shlomo Rav Shlomo Zalman
Auerbach in chelek alef siman yud-tet ot zayin
says three regalim. If you spend all three
regalim in eretz yisrael then you can keep
one day yom tov. If you don't spend
all three regalim
in eretz yisrael then you're a ben chutz
la-aretz you keep you have to keep two
days of yom tov. lich'ora that's also somewhat
arbitrary. Why should it depend on three regalim?
What I'm a ben eretz yisrael for regalim
klapei regalim? A little bit difficult to understand.
Either you're ben eretz yisrael or you're a
you're a ben chutz la-aretz. Why davka? Let's
say you have a person who spends five
months, six months out of the year in
eretz yisrael but he's only there for two
of the regalim. He doesn't come back shavuot
time, he comes goes to America for the
summer or something. So such a person is
not a ben eretz yisrael? Difficult to imagine
that it should be based on three regalim.
So says Rav Asher Weiss he thinks what
it should all he thinks that it really
depends on where you are at the time
that you at the time of the yom
tov provided that you actually have a home
in both places and there is nothing tying
you to one home over the other. Meaning
if a person has young children and they're
in yeshiva in New York you can't say
that you're a ben eretz yisrael. Very diff—meaning
there's a reason that you have to be
in New York for ten months out of
the year and you can't not be there.
You have to be there for your children.
So very very difficult to say that one
is a ben eretz yisrael. Or if a
person when he goes to eretz yisrael he's
a guest at a hotel. He's not a
he's he's living like a tourist. He's not
living like a person who has a home.
So that's not a ben eretz yisrael. But
a person who has a home and he
has nothing tying him to one home or
the other, so he may spend much more
time in his home in chutz la-aretz but
still says Rav Asher lich'ora that would fit
into that category of someone who has the
status. of a ben Eretz Yisrael when in
Eretz Yisrael and a ben chutz l'aretz when
in chutz l'aretz. And in fact, once you
add in the three shitos that we started
with, meaning that that there are many shitos
that those three shitos that hold Rebbi Yaakov
Emden and the Chacham Tzvi and Rav David
Luria that hold that anyway ben chutz l'aretz
only keeps one day, even though we don't
pasken that way, that's at least another snif
l'hakel and in addition in the Shut Chaim
Shaal chelek aleph siman nun-hey when he discusses
bachurim that travel to Eretz Yisrael that a
lot of the Rabbanei Yerushalayim pasken that if
they plan on going back to chutz l'aretz
they should observe sheni Yom Tov shel Galuyot
and the Chida disagreed and he said well,
if these bachurim while in Eretz Yisrael they
meet a girl and they an Israeli girl
and they decide to marry her, so they'll
koveia themselves in Eretz Yisrael, that's enough. They're
considered yoshvei Eretz Yisrael. And says the Chida,
since the ikar mitzvas Yom Tov sheni is
only because of sfeika d'yoma and it's only
because of v'hizaharu b'minhag avoseichem b'yadeichem, he says
with a with even a reason kol dehu,
even a tiniest reason, we could be machria
that the person has a status of a
ben Eretz Yisrael. So that's the general tone
that Rav Asher Weiss takes. That since you
have he thinks a very strong sevara that
what determines that I'm a ben this or
a ben that I have homes in both
places, that's the strongest part of the teshuva,
that's the ikar. Plus a snif l'hakel, many
people hold even a ben chutz l'aretz keeps
one day. Plus the overall attitude is that
it doesn't take a ton to say that
a person should have a status of a
ben Eretz Yisrael. So putting all that together,
Rav Asher says that people like my parents,
for example, who do live most of the
year in chutz l'aretz are always there for
shalosh regalim, but go three, four four times
a year at least to Eretz Yisrael, and
when they go, they're in their own home,
they're in their their own their own place,
they're not going like tourists and there are
a lot of people like this, they would
have a status of a ben Eretz Yisrael
while in Eretz Yisrael and a ben chutz
l'aretz while in chutz l'aretz.